believe it or not Windows is now faster
on an Apple M2 MacBook Air than on an
actual Windows laptop and not an old one
a new Windows laptop like the XPS plus
which is one of the most popular ones
and in this video I'm going to show you
how it's faster I'm going to show you
how to download and install parallels 18
because that's the version we're using
because they put in a ton of
optimizations this year making it a lot
faster and more convenient to download
So before I show you guys how crazy fast
Windows is on the Mt MacBook Air with
parallels I'm going to drop a link to
parallels 18 in the description below so
you can download it but you'll also need
a Windows license key and thankfully we
partnered up with our sponsors software
keep so you can get 20 off a genuine
Windows 10 or Windows 11 license now as
you know there are so many fishy
websites out there that could scam you
but software keep is a Microsoft
certified gold partner who sells only
100 genuine micro soft software so you
don't have to worry which resulted in
software keep earning over a hundred
thousand five star reviews and not only
can you get a killer price for windows
with an instant download but they are
extremely popular for Microsoft Office
365 and you can also save money by
buying a lifetime license instead of a
subscription version and on top of that
they also have great prices on other
software including the most popular
antivirus and their customer service is
phenomenal with 24 7 365 customer
support where you'll talk to a real
person instead of a robot so buy a
Windows key for parallels or anything
else you need today and save 20 off
they're already great prices by using
the link in the description and the
coupon code Max Tech 20. all right and
here we go we got Windows 11 installed
with parallels 18 on the M2 MacBook Air
is actually very easy and you'll see how
easy it is in the install guide later on
in this video but I want to show how
awesome this is check this out we have
Windows 11 but you still have access to
your dock yes you can use all of your
Mac apps at the same time you still have
your menu bar for Mac while using
Windows 11. this is incredible this is
where you get this for the people who
want windows for some specific apps that
are required to have Windows but you
also want the Mac because you want the
super nice design you don't want to hear
any fan noise which is very annoying
with a lot of Windows laptops like the
XPS plus which turns on the fans just to
restart the system itself which is kind
of crazy but you also want windows at
the same time so this is a perfect
solution with parallels 18 and now let
me show you guys the performance
difference and how fast this is by
testing geekbench 5 under parallels 18
in Windows 11. now while this is running
I do want to make a point about the
prices because this empty MacBook Air is
less expensive than the Dell XPS plus
that we compared it to that one was a
1850 yes a thousand eight hundred fifty
dollars compared to this one sixteen
hundred with 16 gigs of RAM and 5 12
gigs SSD and you'll see the performance
difference and boom there you go we have
a result take a look at that score 16.81
for a single core and 72.60 for
multi-core that's actually 42 faster
than the Dell XPS plus unplugged which
is how you're going to be using your
laptop in most cases and 32 faster in
multi-core and the crazy thing is even
if you plug in the Dell XPS to feed it
more power because of course the battery
life on those machines is not good and
those chips take a lot of power
especially the new ones you're still
beating it out in terms of single core
performance and it's almost as good in
terms of the multi-core performance
that's just crazy that this is running
in parallels 18 Windows 11 and it's
getting this much performance but wait
let me show you the web browsing perform
with the speedometer Benchmark and there
you go check that out even under Windows
11 in parallels we got 228 runs per
minute for the web browsing speed which
is faster than the XPS plus the fastest
score we got there was 209 so that is
unbelievable that even through all that
translation going on in Windows 11 of
course it's even faster in Mac OS itself
over 300 points or even close to 400
points which is crazy we still got this
much in Windows 11 that is awesome now
on top of that you are also getting a
lot of benefits by choosing to go with
the M2 MacBook Air with parallels 18 to
run the Windows task that you need
because you're also getting the better
webcam you're getting the awesome
display you're getting the awesome thin
and light design no fan noise ever you
don't have to worry about that you have
features like Max save 3 and of course
you have the resale value which is a big
reason people buy Max instead of Windows
laptops because they are very reliable
and they last for many many years
without breaking or starting to mess up
like a lot of the Windows laptops
unfortunately do however I did run into
a couple of issues with Windows 11
through parallels 18 because I think
this is a new M2 Chip not everything is
supported yet like I tried to run
DaVinci Resolve 18 and it says that I
have an unsupported GPU processing node
so it looks like it does need to get
updated because it is not showing so
DaVinci Resolve currently is not working
but that's okay because it's a
cross-platform app and you can simply
run it on the Mac OS version right
alongside Windows 11 with parallels 18
which is a really nice and convenient
thing and it is super fast on the M2
MacBook Air faster than the windows
competition now on top of that I also
try to install Adobe Creative Cloud to
run Lightroom classic to test out the
speed but once again the installation
failed because it cannot be run from a
network drive so it seems like a
parallels 18 issue I'm not sure but it's
not a big deal because it's also
cross-platform and Incredibly fast
within Mac OS on the M2 MacBook Air so
that's really nice that we have those
cross-platform apps with that said I
think parallels 18 is a huge upgrade
compared to before and it is the best
way to run Windows 11 on a Mac machine
and with that said let's go over to the
installation guide all right now getting
into the installation process for
parallels 18 on Mac OS the first thing
you're going to do is go to the actual
website parallels.com you can find an
easy link to it down in the description
and pinned comment below so definitely
use that let's click download free trial
and it should direct you to the download
click allow and there you go open it up
in your downloads folder and then just
double click on install Parallels
Desktop click OK through these prompts
and there you go go ahead and put your
Mac password as the download finishes up
then go through the permissions that you
need to accept just click OK on
everything here to give it access and
boom right there it says download and
install Windows 11 and it should start
creating it and installing it by itself
which is awesome with a new parallels 18
update and there you go the download is
finished it's asking us if it wants
access to the camera let's do don't
allow I don't think that matters don't
allow the microphone either we don't
really need that unless you do and here
you go the installation of Windows 11 is
going and boom the installation is
complete let's click to continue and
here you're going to put in your login
credentials for parallels or basically
create an account and there you go we're
in Windows 11 as you can see we have the
web browser open so we can go ahead and
close that there's our desktop we have
our Windows updates if you choose to
download those you can do that as well
there you go that was incredibly easy
good job parallels 11 and that's how you
install it so hopefully you enjoyed this
whole video with all the testing we did
showing off how good this M2 MacBook Air
is and if you enjoyed it click the
circle above to subscribe definitely
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]